hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
wow so like this video has been
requested for like
many many many many months and we're
finally doing it
today i'm gonna show you my notion setup
this video is actually sponsored by
notion so thank you to notion for
working with me on this one
i genuinely love their product even
before they sponsored me
i like really really really
enjoyed using it so it just made a lot
of sense that we worked together on this
and i am
so stoked to show you my notion setup so
for those of you who are unfamiliar
notion is basically like a productivity
tool you can take
notes with it you can make task lists
you can create calendars you can
collaborate with other people
it's one of those tools that like you
can really use it however way you want
and it's
really freaking powerful so today i'm
gonna walk you through like
my current notion set up walk you
through some of the most important pages
that i use
on a day-to-day basis and then kind of
the second half of the video i'm going
to show you some like my favorite
features
and tools and tips and tricks for using
notion real talk though i used to like
not like notion actually i used to come
from like other productivity management
and
note-taking apps and i thought it was
like not a good app
but a friend introduced me to one after
we had kind of like a collaborative
calendar
table thing and ever since then i'm like
wow
this thing is actually great but yes i
was once a hater but now i'm
such a huge fan i'm like recommending it
to everyone i can
i like create shared pages with
everybody because i'm like i want them
to know
the greatness of notion so hopefully by
the end of this video
you will also feel that way or you'll
just enjoy looking at what i look at
every day
if at any point you're interested in
using notion and signing up then you can
use the link in the description box down
below
would appreciate you using that link
instead of googling it because then it
gets attributed to me
and maybe they want to work with me on
another video because i love it
i love notion thank you notion thank you
for existing
i love you all right so here is my
notion
uh i have my planner as kind of like my
home
page my like dashboard and we'll get
into that a bit
but i do kind of want to start off by
talking about my calendar
so i use notion primarily for all of
this
stuff planning videos writing videos
coordinating videos
as well as just like other things as
well sponsorships
newsletter muko's corner like literally
anything that has to do with like my
work is all on notion
because a lot of my work is like
deadline driven there's like a million
things happening at once
i like to have just like one calendar
that gives me
a 30 000 foot view about all the things
that are happening
right now so i had my assistant make
this for me and it is
so useful like so incredibly useful
so the content calendar basically has
many lists inside of it we have a master
list that kind of has
all of the different stuff that i'm
working on all in one place
and they all have this property called
database which then sorts each
thing into like is it a sponsorship is
it newsletter is it video content
and so on the left side you can see like
here the newsletters that
i had planned i'm working on relaunching
it right now so stay tuned but it's a
little bear right now
and then video content as well here are
all the videos that i worked on in 2021
i have muco's corner stuff here i have
sponsorships
as well as just like happenings etc etc
so
these are all kind of just like the
different aspects
of my life in work that i have and i can
see
all of that together in the calendar i'm
not someone who really likes putting
like
video timelines or tasks in my actual
calendar
mostly just because i feel like it gets
colored like i like to use my actual
gmail calendar
as like a event calendar and not like
a work task calendar and so it's really
nice that notion has this
capability to do so so by looking at the
content calendar i basically get a sense
of like all right what am i working on
this week and next week
which then informs what i put into my
planner so a lot of people use planners
on notion a lot of people use like
dashboards
some people make like habit tracking
things as well as like diaries journal
entries dream logs
i use mine really as kind of like a
bullet journal replacement
i used to bullet journal a lot in like a
paper and pen
medium but not so much anymore because i
found this
and really it's just because all of my
stuff is in the content calendar all of
my video things are all here
and so it makes sense that my planner is
also here so my planner itself i have a
little area at the top for like what am
i focusing on this week what are my
intentions just like notes from myself
and then i also have dates deadlines and
dates to meet this week again this is
like
a not a 30 000 foot view but like a 5
000 foot view about like okay what's
happening this week
what are my intentions and what are my
goals and then i have this kind of like
monday through friday
spread basically every day in the
morning i go to the day that it is and
then i type in what am i committing to
today and as i go throughout the day i
can check back and be like okay what
else do i have to do i can check off
things
it's just easy and organized and then
underneath this like monday through
friday spread i do have like a rolling
task list
because sometimes things aren't urgent
but they still need to be done
and i don't exactly know when i'm gonna
be doing things
so another thing that i'll do usually on
monday mornings is to
fill this out with like all the things
that i'm doing that week or in the
future
this is also really helpful because i
tend to sign up for a lot of things and
say yes to things
but i don't always like remember to do
them so if i say yes to something they
just immediately go in here
it's kind of just like okay and just
just so that i make sure i don't forget
let's just like put it in the rolling
task list i don't know when it's going
to be done but it is on my radar
so that's my planner i also made a
planner for my writer assistant
and editor so so that they have a space
that they can kind of just like
think on and like plan on as well so in
addition to
calendars and planners i also use this
as like a note-taking device
so you'll see in like my 2021 plan which
is a living breathing document
that really is just my brain dumping
stuff
i have just a bunch of notes about like
this is what i want to be doing this
year
i made this at the beginning of the year
just so that i like can stay focused and
like okay
what are my goals like what are the
things that i should be thinking about
what am i committing to doing and when
so it's just a place for me to think
really
the next part that i really want to dive
into for my notion setup is this
video tab alright so this is where like
all the magic happens these are where
all of my videos are
so i basically just like have this as
like a rolling
task list again for videos um all of my
scheduled videos go into this
content calendar because i all have a
target date i get to
set like the status for things as well
as like final versions of scripts
outlines of scripts who's the writer
who's the editor and then the type of
video that i'm making
i also watch a lot of like notion set up
videos because
similar to like bullet journal videos
they're very soothing and i'm just like
wow i'm like so productive i'm watching
how to be productive
and so i took a note out of thomas
frank's video about
uh creating like this nice little video
template
for how to like create videos basically
this is the one for this video it's a
little bear because i just have an
outline
the video that i published yesterday
about like transitioning out of college
and becoming an adult has a very
full page and so at the top i kind of
talk about like okay what is this video
about what's the one liner about
what the topic is i have a timeline
um for all the different parts it's
really just a gantt chart
uh to see like what are people doing
when to get this thing out
and then i also have a storyboard which
has the script on the left side and the
shot on the right side
right i have title ideas tags and
keyword sponsor info this is very
similar to thomas frank's setup
and then on the content side of things i
have like a bunch of different things
research outline scratch pads all the
different drafts and the final script
so that's my content calendar underneath
all of this i also have like
ideas for future videos so whenever i
think of an idea i just like dump it in
here because
maybe it's not ready to be created but
if i'm always like
what video am i gonna make next which
happens all the time i can just go to
this list
i also have a list for videos from my
japanese channel here as well
basically lists lists on lists on lists
tables
so freaking useful on notion next is
kind of the business
side of things i have like branding
payment info merch stuff i also have my
sponsorship calendar in here as well
to show me like who is sponsoring what
at
when um rates stuff about the ad length
and placement
that all goes on to the content calendar
as well i used to have the video and
like the sponsorship really tied
together where it was related to just
like one item
and one item had all of the information
about the video and a sponsor but i
decoupled them because i started making
like
videos specifically just for brands and
i'm like no i want to make videos that
brands sponsor
uh and i want to have creative control
and so i've made those two into
different entities so that when i go
into the content calendar
i can move like maybe this video is not
sponsored by brilliant
maybe this video is and so it's easy to
kind of just like
decouple all those things and then the
rest i have like meeting notes so
anytime i'm meeting with anybody i have
like a running meeting note list
to just like have a place to like
scratch pad it out
it's all very jumbled and whatever um i
also have muco's corner stuff here
newsletters future ideas that i bump
into
and i just like put it all down in
somewhere so it's not in my brain
um a happenings page etc like it's
i use notion for like many different
things and so these are all the kind of
like different spaces
in my broader workspace to help me
organize myself
all right so for this part of the video
i'm going to show you some of my
favorite features that like
really made me fall in love with notion
and we're kind of going to do like a
pair programming style for this one
hopefully the demo gods are here with me
and i
can do things without messing up but you
know what
this is edited so my editor can edit out
to my mistakes
maybe okay so the first thing you
guessed it is tables and databases
so i'm going to make a new page maybe
let's call it just like social life
stuff maybe i want to track things on my
social life so
uh you can create various elements in a
notion
page one of which is a
table you can make it inline or whatever
so you can create a table
and let's call this like events so
tables in notion
work very similarly to like literal
databases
so let's say like okay hang out um like
potluck let's add a few things here uh
what are the social events concert
um hangout and then let's add another
like um thing here
maybe multi-select with who let's call
um
hang out with uh james and sarah i don't
know who these people are
and um lulu openness lulu um for
instance and then the potluck is like
lulu and the concerts with sarah and
like this one's with james for instance
um and then i can set also a date for
like when
and i can also be like where um i think
this has to be text though yes
so when i don't know like this day that
day like this day and
that day where louise house lulu's house
uh golden gate park
and james house for instance so now i
have like a pretty good like database
so one of the things that you can do on
a table on notion
is you can filter things and it really
is just like
it's your querying for certain things so
let's say
um let's create a filter for
um hangouts with lulu so contains
lulu so now i can see that i'm hanging
out with her
and i also have a potluck scheduled with
her so you can set a lot of filters you
can add
multiple filters you can add filter
groups
pretty powerful here um it's really
like nice to be able to see all of these
different things and then you can also
sort things as well so let's get rid of
the filter
remove because i don't believe this is
sorted so now i can set a sort
and let's say it's sorted
from most recent to later
just later okay so yeah tables databases
really nice say that now i also wanted
to create a calendar view of this this
is kind of one of the really nice
things about notion a view lets you see
the same database in multiple ways
so because this is like a social life
calendar like i i want a calendar
so let's set a calendar now it takes all
of the stuff that i entered into
the table and based on the date that i
have
it sets it as a calendar which is really
nice so now i can see exactly like oh
this week i have a potluck i had a
potluck yesterday i would hang out
tomorrow next week i have a concert and
a hangout
and then you can also create like
specific
calendars with a certain sort
and filter so let's say let's say i want
to make a calendar
called uh lulu so these are
all the times that i'm hanging out with
lulu okay where's the filter
filter and then
i say with who contains lulu
so i'm hanging out with her this week
you can have just so many different ways
of looking at one view
um calendar and table are one of the
most like
common things that i use you can also
use it for a combo board which is really
nice
for project planning and bug tracking so
it's very similar to like other
bug tracking task things out there
you can also see it as a list a gallery
there's just so many ways to like
see one set of data at once and i like
the flexibility of that
because you do want to be able to see
like you want to enter it once and view
it in many different cuts because
all of those cuts and views are good for
a different thing
so yes tables and databases in notion i
think one of the strongest
best features of this thing so the next
thing that i really really like about
notion
is templates so basically on notion you
can create
your own templates for pages and you can
also use other people's templates as
well
so if you click into this templates
thing here it'll show you some pre-made
notion templates and right now this is
very like
in a tech company you have design
engineering human resources etc etc but
it's also used often for school so
taking class notes for job applications
grade calculator
it's all very extensive and obviously
you don't have to use every single thing
of the template
but what i do often is i'll find a
template in here
that i like copy paste it and then kind
of make my own version of it like it's
cool because it's like
sometimes you don't know exactly what
the best way to like format all of your
information is at the end of the day
like
notion gets you really good at
information architecture and
kind of helps like create a mind palace
on paper from your brain
and seeing other templates do that like
seeing examples of how others do it
is really helpful for like okay this is
a good way of like laying out different
things
the other thing too about templates is
that you're not limited to just these
templates
you can also browse more templates
because a lot of people have made lots
of different templates out there
there's just so many different things
like everything from
like non-profit fundraising to a
brainstorm
to um i've seen some really interesting
stuff in here before
uh disaster prep plan like what's your
earthquake plan
kind of an example of like a resume that
you can write out
if you need a space to do so you can
also export as a pdf
if you want and then kind of in this
part like oh my goodness
puppers if you want like a thing of all
of your dogs
um here's ollie abdull's 2020 annual
review template
i really like take a lot of inspiration
from all these videos for notion and
just other live stuff as well so his
stuff is in there
as well as bullet journal i believe is
in here as well
i think i took mine from probably matt's
actually my friend matt ragland it's
kind of similar he's
kind of a bullet journal aficionado he
made this template
there's a couple i think i actually took
it from this one now that i think about
it this looks very similar to what i
have right now
you can create a recipe book
like really the limits are and like
there are no limits
when you think about what you can do
with notion there's actually like a
subreddit for notion
and i've been looking in there for inspo
and a lot of people make their notion
pages so
pretty like just visually but also
really well organized about
many many different things oh here's the
thomas frank video production one that i
kind of
used and remixed into my own so yeah
there's just so many different like
templates that if you don't know where
to start
like because sometimes starting
something from scratch is hard and scary
if you just take something that you like
through a template and then just make it
your own
great and so i have templates set up for
like videos here so if i create a brand
new video
new video and i open this page then i
have the
option to use the video template and
yeah so now i have all this stuff here
already and i can already start working
on my video
alright the next thing i want to talk
about that i love in notion is
collaboration
so notion has a lot of different like
tiers and pricing depending on how many
people are in your team
and if people are on your team then they
get access to everything
but a lot of the time i just want to
share like one page with one person
because
i'm working on one project with like
another youtuber
or i'm writing notes with somebody from
one specific meeting you can add people
as guests
to specific pages by clicking share and
then adding people and their emails
so that they can see just that page i
actually have like a lot of guests in my
notion
especially just because i want everyone
to use it when i was writing like my ted
talk for instance
i had my speaker liaison person i was
just like can we
like agree to just like use notion as a
living breathing document for my script
and he was like sure i've never even
used it
so i invited him to my notion page and
we both
got to like comment on things and edit
things
and that's kind of the workflow that i
have with my team right now and it's
proving to be
very very useful i also get added to
like notions of like friends and family
and stuff like when my brother
was planning to move back to the states
he created like a notion page of like
here's my game plan i'm gonna share this
with miyuko so she can look it over and
see if it's sound
and it's free like adding guests to your
notion is free and i think that's a
really really
useful thing also whoever you invite
onto notion they don't have to have the
app downloaded they it creates like a
url that you can look at
on the web and so it really like the
whole
process is really streamlined there's
not really a lot of like barriers of
entry into using notion
but of course being like the notion
aficionado i am i have it downloaded as
a desktop app because i like using
desktop apps more than web apps
i also have the ipad app which i don't
know if you can see this but
it has my outline for this video that
i'm looking at while i
film and then of course i have it on my
phone
uh because sometimes i just want to look
at stuff quickly
and i also have it as a widget notion
has widgets on iphone and so my planner
link is right here so if i tap on that
it'll just show my planner so i can see
like on the go what am i supposed to be
working on
the next thing that i want to talk about
which i think is like this
is what a lot of people talk about this
is really like one of the other main
powers of notion i think
is the formatting capabilities so when
it comes to like note taking and putting
like thoughts
into this um it's very like simple and
easy
to like add stuff but it also follows a
similar kind of like
formatting style to markdown so one
pound is like a heading one
two pounds is like a heading two three
pounds heading three
and then you can also like bold things
like all of the basic
things obviously that you can do you can
also add code blocks
in notion which i feel like these days
uh like so important to be able to do
that so you can
either create a code block where you can
convert things into a code block and
they have lots of different
programming languages that it recognizes
and so it'll actually like
do the formatting and color coding and
stuff for that programming language
you can also create like toggles um
you can also create quotes the quick
round
fox jumped over the lazy dog i believe
one of my favorite things right now is
call
outs just because sometimes you do want
to call out something but not bold it
like you want to make it look different
so like remember to brush your teeth
or something like that so yeah there's a
lot of different things
that you can do to format things if you
use the slash command you can see
all of the different things that are at
your disposal oh i also like adding
dividers to things
what else you can mention people you can
embed certain things so
i like to embed videos i like to embed
pdfs
and you can also add files there's also
a lot of like
integrations with lots of other
apps and stuff as well so if you just
connect the two
great notion actually i think rolled out
a notion api recently and so you can
even build against
notion on your own oh and colors colors
are important
colors you can set text colors and
background colors to
whatever you want the last feature that
i want to talk about on notion
is the whole hot keys feature this is
really what
makes me think that like notion is like
a pro tool for heavy users
cause you know that if an application
has
hot keys it means that they mean
business you know
like it means that there are people who
can't be bothered to use
their mouse because they're so busy
writing stuff or coding stuff
but also it's just nice i like using
hotkeys for things and i'm by no means
like
hotkeys like expert like i still use my
mouse but
it's still nice to be able to quickly
get to things so the first one that i
just showed is if you use a slash
command
then you can like quickly create
something like that
or you can create like a table or
something it's very similar to kind of
like the whole like slash commands on
slack or discord or whatever
another hotkey that i use often is
command p which quickly opens stuff so
if i want to open
something a specific page then it's just
easy to get there because sometimes
things get really embedded like far
down into things and you don't want to
like click around for it so
that's easy it's kind of like a command
space sort of deal
the other hotkey that i use often is
like command shift n
that creates like a new page on notion
and so you can have
two different pages side by side you can
also close the sidebar
with command back slash and so you can
just have like
only these two pages and i like doing
that because sometimes you want to look
at a one-page
notion while writing in another of
course you can do command n for like a
new page
and then command enter to create to make
this page like full screen
those are all typical hotkeys that you'd
see
in like coding ides and they're really
all here
so yeah that's pretty much it those are
all the features that i like as well as
a little walkthrough of my current
notion setup
i'm not like a notion expert like i love
notion but i still feel like there's so
much that i don't know about it and it's
really fun to kind of learn more about
the tool
and like see how it works for me and my
use cases
it kind of feels like learning a new
program sort of so i feel like it's
really well suited for like developer
types
so let me know what you think have you
used notion before maybe you already
love notion what features do you like
the best part about notion is that for
your own personal account it's free
and so you can just kind of download it
and see if you like it try to create a
couple of things for your work life or
your personal life
i always always have it up and running
on my computer
so that i can easily get to it because
it's really just like
i hate storing information up here i
like putting it
somewhere and because i can type faster
than i write i tend to put it all on
notion
i also use notion for my hongko academy
and it really helps me my co-founder to
stay organized about all the tasks and
all the notes and stuff and so like
it's very much proved to me that it's an
important necessity in my life
so again if you're interested in using
notion then sign up using the link in
description box down below and let me
know what you think
also if you have any like template
recommendations and stuff send them my
way cause i
freaking love templates so thank you all
so much for watching
make sure to click the like button if
you liked this setup let me know what
other setup tours you'd like to see in
the future in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe and i will see
you next time bye